[Music]
now on to the latest on the fatal
accident valving bachelor star Chris
soules
for the first time we're hearing from
someone who was at the scene of the
crash in rural Iowa it's just a tragic
tragic situation for the City of Aurora
David Young was one of the first
responders on the scene when bachelor
Chris soules rear-ended this farmers
tractor the accident happened at dusk on
this stretch of a rural County Road just
after 8:00 p.m. young who is the mayor
of Aurora Iowa and also a firefighter
attempted CPR when he first arrived at
the scene so where was Chris soules he
was gone before I got there or he wasn't
at the body when I got there a source
close to Souls family tells ET that
Souls was not drunk and that he left the
scene because he was in shock the 35
year old reality star has hired a team
of attorneys from Des Moines to
represent him Souls rep says that Chris
quote acted reasonably after the crash
in a statement he points out that Souls
called 911 explained his role in the
terrible accident i rear-ended a guy on
a tractor yesterday prosecutors asked
the court to delay Seoul's preliminary
hearing which is currently set for
Tuesday meanwhile 66 year-old Kenneth
Mosier will be laid to rest on Monday